The situation has been tense for years.
It's on June the fifth,
2017.
Suddenly the conflict reached another
dimension,
Arabia,
the Arab Emirates,
Bahrain and Egypt announced the
fulminating rupture of their relations
with the emirate of Qatar,
including the closing of borders and the
prohibition of the use of ports of
asked.
Nice.
Certainly old communication was cut off.
It was practically a total block aid.
The next night planes and cargo ships
bound for Qatar were forced to change
course,
not even the camels were spared.
The Saudis immediately expelled is no
less than 12,000
camels that were grazing in that
country.
Yep.
You heard that right?
So were there any land border closed up
in practical terms,
the emirate of Qatar went from being a
peninsula to becoming an island,
threatens by its neighbors,
by land,
sea,
and air.
At the time this was happening,
these questions were asked,
how long can guitar hold on for?
Are we facing the preview to a military
intervention and has this emirate
splendor reached its end?
Well,
today in this video we're going to see
exactly what happens,
how things are today,
and what we can expect in the future
results.
Now we are going to see the results,
but first,
what you might be wondering,
bow,
did they get into this situation in the
first place?
What the hell happened as an almost all
disputes.
There are lots of reasons on the table,
but the truth is that the regardance Abu
Dhabi government swept tires.
If Guitar always being free than to
bubble,
they wanted to cast off their growing
relations with Iran and closed down Al
Jazeera once and for all.
In fact,
these were the basic conditions that
were imposed on guitar in order to start
a dialogue after agreeing on the
blockades conditions that Doha outright
rejects it.
But having said all of that,
let's get right to the point at first,
everyone bed that this whole mess would
be temporary and that it would resolve
relatively quickly one way or another.
After all,
who would think that such a small
country,
the country that has barely 2 million
inhabitants and that is practically a
desert,
would be able to resist for very long
without simply giving up.
It seems pretty impossible,
right?
Well,
to view it,
that's precisely what is happening.
It has not resulted in the way they
wanted it to.
They wanted to take control of our
decisions and get us to comply with
their demands that has failed.
Katara will never be for sale to the
blockade in countries or to anyone else.
We are a sovereign country.
We will remain a sovereign country safe.
I'll punny,
director of Qatar's government
communications office.
As you can imagine,
throughout the first few hours,
the emirate underwent a very,
very tense situation.
Many supplies including basic products
such as food stopped arriving,
the stock market collapsed,
and even the option of military
intervention didn't seem far fetched.
After all,
the smoke Itsari army was no match for
the billion dollar war machines of its
neighboring countries.
Now,
a successful intervention that dependent
on the approval of the United States,
which has one of its most important
military bases in the world located in
guitar,
even though this approval was likely
just in case heart decided to ask for
Istanbul's help,
Turkish parliament approved spill to
deploy troops in Qatar the situation
well,
it was looking to be quite difficult and
quite complex,
but hold on a moment because Qatar well
bad,
another ace up their sleeve as we told
you,
you in a previous video in recent years,
the Emirates,
they've done their homework thanks to
its oil and especially natural gas
exploitation.
If the country has managed to accumulate
a fortune of more than $300,000,000,000
a fortune by the way that they've
invested all over the planet.
Yes,
and not only that,
but it also managed to become a country
that's much more open to the world as a
country with a foreign policy that's
independent of its.
It's precisely what made this blockade
total failure.
Yeah.
Blockade Strategy was corner us
economically that has completely failed
and it will not work.
Alisha reef,
I'll mid finance,
minister of Qatar.
You see,
in recent months the stock market has
recovered investors,
they've stopped running away and even
though many prices rose due to the
blockade,
even the international monetary funds in
a report published on March the fifth,
2018 stated that the Qatari economy
would grow by almost three percent this
year.
Yeah,
x is that the country hasn't only
managed to open new commercial rates and
achieve alternatives to transport it's
merchandise.
Many multinationals like aged in Dubai,
you can no longer send that.
People by playing to Doha have decided
to open that own officers there.
This means that,
for example,
the number of companies in the financial
center has grown by 70 percent in the
last year,
past 15 years.
We were the fastest growing economy on
the planet.
You're talking about a $6,000,000,000
economy in 2000 turning into a $200,
billion dollar economy in 2015.
The blockading countries tried to make
businesses decide between them and
Qatar,
but they backed away.
Yusuf Mohammed,
al Qaeda,
the head of the Qatar financial
authority to view it.
It might actually seem that this
blockade might actually ends up helping
Qatar if you don't believe me well,
perhaps listens to this in Qatar.
Kate,
it has clearly been a challenge for the
Qatari economy and their society.
Having an isolated country like that.
It's generally a really terrible deal
now,
precisely due to that during this time,
one of the Emirates government's biggest
priorities has been to compensate for
the blockades,
negative consequences,
and convince investors that cutoff is
still a good country to invest in
and to try and gain a lot of influence
around the world.
This is something that's indispensable
to prevent it to nate as especially
Saudi Arabia from guessing future
expansionist temptations,
but now you may be wondering,
well,
how can they achieve out of this?
Well,
one way is by pushing reformance and
that's something they've done in recent
months.
The Qatari government has promoted
several changes to improve the country's
image in the world and to be more
competitive for international investors.
For example,
visas have been removed for more than 80
countries.
The rights of foreign residents have
increased and more free zones have been
established.
Further two very important changes have
been announced for one,
they called for elections for the very
first time to elect members for the
consultive assembling something like a
local parliaments.
Now this is a pretty limited
parliaments,
but at least it's a step in the right
direction and this is a particularly
important step when we account for the
fact that we're talking about is a place
that still works with a political system
based on absolute monarchy and for
another.
The more than reprehensible could follow
system will be coming to an end.
This is a system that makes foreign
workers,
especially the poorest,
have to rely on their employers for that
visa and legal status and has very few
legal repercussions for exploitation
making,
working conditions very,
very bad.
In some cases,
you've probably heard of the allegations
about slave workers in the Persian Gulf.
Well,
this is what we're talking about.
However,
now with the latest labor changes,
all of these workers will have better
protected rights and we'll be able to
change jobs or leave the country
whenever they want.
All of these reforms would have taken a
lot longer were it not?
For the blockade,
it's been a blessing in disguise when it
comes to business.
You see Mohammed algae,
Aida,
head of the Qatar financial authority.
In other words,
the blockade is achieving things that
the international community has been
demanding for years,
but having said that,
we still have a very,
very important question to answer.
Do you know what Qatar strategy has been
to gain influence in the world and
strengthen its position?
Well,
listen up
the strategy.
We
all know that there are very economic
sectors in the welds.
Well,
two industries in particular,
standout one due to its ability to
influence politics and another due to
its ability to influence society.
Yes,
I'm talking about the military industry
and the entertainment industry and you
know what?
It's precisely in these industries that
Qatar has concentrated its strategy.
In recent months,
the Qatari government has announced
military contracts for more than
$25,000,000,000
and yes,
one of their objectives is to equip that
army to,
if necessary,
make invasions more difficult.
But the truth is that no matter how much
they invest in weapons,
Catala Williams be able to replicate
Saudi Arabia's military power.
But wait just a moment because there's
another objective,
what better way to influence Washington
and get support than by making an
industry that practically every
government in the world consider
strategic happy.
In this case,
most of the contracts went to the United
States and European countries that
didn't support the blockade is whether
United Kingdom,
France and Germany,
planes,
tanks,
helicopters,
Ms Dot [inaudible] is buying everything.
Of course it's never going to be able to
reach Saudi Arabia's level,
but it hasn't suddenly become a very
prominent clients.
Yes.
The truth is that Qataris are really
experts in contracting security
policies.
Hello,
by the way,
don't hire resorts to announced that he
wants to invest more money in our
indies,
a based in the United States military
has in the country.
This is a base with more than 10,000
soldiers and 100 deployed aircrafts
including b,
Fifty two bombers.
As we mentioned,
it is one of the most important to
United States spaces in the world.
Yes,
it's really from Qatar where the United
States projects it strengthened the area
and this includes Fritz incursions into
Iraq,
Afghanistan,
Syria,
etc.
Etc.
By the way,
the base cost a billion dollars and was
a gift from the qatari government who
also contributes to their expenses for.
YEah,
so yeah,
suffice to say it was really quite a
bargain for washing
for us.
Thanks.
cut her fridge.
Standing support of america's commitment
to read,
no security to include the information
sharing and encountered at first
and just in case our signs,
an agreement with Turkey to establish a
naval base in its territory.
Now in the other industry,
the entertainment industry,
guitar has Been moving like a fish in
water for years,
especially as far as sports are
concerned.
In 2022,
the country will host the world cup in
2012.
It bought psd,
francis most important football team and
doha.
The country's capital has been an
olympic contender several times and also
knew that so they also created bind
sports and al jazeera subsidiary that
has become one of the largest sports
competition broadcasting rights owners
in the world.
Well,
after announcing the blockades,
the qatari authorities decided to
reinforce the strategy,
which for example,
there's the psg to spend billions and
billions of dollars on signing
along with joining psg on a five year
contract,
and $354 million dollars.
Name are also committed to act as
spokesmen for the Qatar world cup in
this way,
not only did psg acquire the player who
would elevate the team's presence on the
european stage,
but cut are obtained,
a symbol of it's defiance in the face of
it's attempted isolation of doula.
I'll rn assistant professor of history
at georgetown university school of
foreign service in Qatar,
well with the military industry,
with football and by pouring millions of
dollars into Washington lobbyists,
the Qatari government hopes to reinforce
its position and improve its image.
Now,
of course,
that rivals are also beginning to make
moves.
Say the battle is not over yet,
but that's something we can talk about
another day.
For now,
it's your turn.
What country do you think will be
reinforced by this blockade?
Well,
leave as you're answering the comments
below it.
In this survey,
we really do like knowing about your
opinion and I really hope you enjoy this
video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
monday and every thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check it.
Our friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thank you for watching.